Speaker 1: And speaking of people who have
things working in their favor, it was recently
reported that U.S. Postmaster General Louis
Dejoy has awarded a massive contract.
The post office has awarded a massive contract.
He swears he wasn't involved in the process,
but they have awarded a massive contract to
a company called XPO Logistics.
And those who have you who have been following
excuse me, Louis Dejoy story for the past
year, I'm sure that company name certainly
rings a bell, right.
Because XPO Logistics happens to be the company
that Louis Dejoy up until October held a massive
financial interest in, but he divested from
that company in October.
Kind of Citizens for Responsibility and Ethics
in Washington says that this is really a sham
divestment because all he did was give all
of his holdings to his children, who in turn
will most likely just give it all back to
him once he is no longer the postmaster general
of the United States.
And again, the contracts being steered towards
XPO that Dejoy swears he didn't have a hand
in total.
One hundred and twenty million dollars, which
could result in a net windfall for the Dejoy
family of 23 million dollars.
So the big question everybody has, of course,
is why is Louis Dejoy still the postmaster
general of the United States?
And the answer is because, man, the post office
infrastructure is set up.
Weird that that is honestly the best way I
can describe it going through.
And I'm not sure if David has explained this,
but I'm going to go ahead and explain it in
a really slimmed down version here.
But to just sum it up, incredibly hard to
remove a postmaster general.
Here's what's happening.
Biden cannot fire Louis Dejoy.
He is powerless to stop Dejoy.
But when he can do is he can appoint new members
to the board of governors, of which he's already
nominated.
Three, they have not been approved.
And then the board of governors are the ones
who get to vote to oust the postmaster general.
Here's a problem, though, there's three vacancies,
Biden's nominated people for those, and if
and when they get approved, Democrats will
have the majority on that board of governors.
So you would think at that point that joyes
history, right?
Nope, because two of the Democrats on that
board of governors were appointed by Trump.
And those same two Democrats actually voted
in favor.
Of this New Deal.
So they're OK with it, they're OK with Dejoy.
So Biden can get his people there.
Democrats will have the majority, but they
still.
Probably not going to remove him at that point,
so then what's the remedy?
Well, I'm glad you asked.
The remedy is Biden can fire members of the
governor's board with cause.
Now, that little statement with cause or four
calls, I think is how it's phrased.
Very difficult.
Because calls can mean anything and cause
can mean nothing.
And cause can be a very specific incident,
depending on which court is looking at it,
and that's what's so worrisome here.
Firing these individuals for not removing
Louis Dejoy for a very obvious conflict of
interest would be considered cause.
Depending on which court hears this case.
Now, does it have to go before court?
Absolutely not.
But if these individuals sue alleging that
there is no cause it would go in front of
a court and the experts have pretty much agreed
that's what would happen if BIID if Biden
fired any of these individuals.
So we are effectively stuck for the moment.
I know we'd like to think that Biden could
do something about this, but honestly, this
is one of those times where his hands are
tied.
And it sucks so bad that that is the position
that we are in, but unfortunately it is the
position that we are in.
And the joy, it appears, is going to continue
to use this position to make as much money
as possible for when that day comes, when
he's no longer the postmaster general.
And to me, that day can't come soon enough.
But I'm worried that it may not come any time
soon.
I am Faran Cousins in for David Pakman.
And don't forget, you can get even more from
me on my YouTube channels.
YouTube dotcom slash the ring of fire, YouTube
dotcom slash fair and balanced.
And I'm on Twitter, Facebook and Instagram
at Fair and Balanced.
We'll be right back with more
of
The David Pakman Show.